House of the Dragon Episode 7 has a funeral
and a wedding....And a dragon flight, and
a child fight – and a fake murder.
So what happens, and what does it mean?
This video has no spoilers for Hot D past
Episode 7.
In the previous episode, Laena Velaryon died.
She was the daughter of Corlys and Rhaenys,
the sister of Laenor, the wife of Daemon,
and the mother of Baela and Rhaena.
So the whole royal family comes to her funeral
on Driftmark.
Many of their dragons also come – the book
says there were so many dragons here, it was
like Driftmark was “the new Valyria”.
Valyria was the great dragonlord empire before
its downfall.
This dragon appears to be Aegon’s dragon,
Sunfyre.
The books say Sunfyre is “the most beautiful”,
and “most magnificent dragon ever”, with
“gleaming golden scales and pale pink wing
membranes”.
And this dragon might be Helaena’s dragon,
Dreamfyre.
Dreamfyre is one of the bigger older dragons,
and is coloured “pale blue” with “with
silvery markings”.
So we’ve now seen eight dragons in Hot D.
Luke and Baela also have dragons that we haven’t
seen yet.
Targaryens burn their dead with dragonfire.
But the Velaryons historically never had dragons.
Their power was ships on the sea.
So Laena’s coffin is laid to rest in the
ocean.
The showrunner says this ritual is called
“the Seat of the Sea”, and that centuries
of Velaryon sarcophagi form the foundation
of the island of High Tide.
Vaemond Velaryon says that the Merling King,
a mermaid god, will guard Laena in the “eternal
waters”.
House Tully’s funeral rites also speak of
an underwater afterlife.
And the ironborn believe that after death
they will party with the Drowned God in his
watery halls like a “wet Valhalla”.
In the books, there are hints that the truth
behind these legends of sea gods, is something
more monstrous and Lovecraftian.
But Laena is laid to rest, and her uncle Vaemond
uses his speech to make a political point.
Vaemond says that Velaryon blood runs true,
and Velaryon blood “must never thin”.
And he looks pointedly at Rhaenyra’s sons
Jace and Luke.
Because Jace and Luke are called Velaryon,
but they don’t really have Laenor Velaryon’s
blood, they’re actually Harwin Strong’s
bastards.
Vaemond’s brother Lord Corlys wants Luke
to inherit Driftmark and be the next Velaryon
lord, but Vaemond doesn’t want that – instead
he mentions Laena’s trueborn daughters Baela
and Rhaena.
They have Velaryon blood, so Vaemond seems
to want them to inherit Driftmark.
We’ve seen Vaemond and Corlys clash before.
This could be the beginning of a succession
dispute within House Velaryon.
Daemon laughs at Vaemond for using a eulogy
for petty politics.
This kind of BS is exactly why Daemon left
court and stayed in Pentos.
Corlys tells Luke he’ll inherit Driftmark
– because Jace is heir to the Throne after
Rhaenyra, and Laenor is king consort.
But Luke says he doesn’t want to be lord,
cause that’ll only happen when more of his
family dies.
These poor kids are traumatised by all the
death and tragedy around them, but the adults
keep pushing them into politics and conflict
for the sake of their ambitions.
Jace knows the truth – he’s not Laenor’s
son, he’s Harwin’s bastard.
So Jace says he should get to mourn his father
and grandfather’s death at Harrenhal.
But Rhaenyra says they both must hide their
grief and pretend that Laenor is Jace’s
father – or else the Velaryons won’t support
them, and as a bastard, Jace’s claim to
the Throne would be weaker.
The adults’ political schemes make their
kids suffer.
Aemond almost speaks to Jace, but they’re
separated by a fire between them, representing
their family’s burning conflict, so Aemond
hesitates and backs off.
Which is tragic, cause if these boys had talked
and connected, maybe they wouldn’t have
had that terrible fight later on.
Helaena Targaryen is the daughter of Viserys
and Alicent, and she likes bugs and saying
mysterious cryptic hit.
So Helaena says “Hand turns loom; spool
of green, spool of black; dragons of flesh
weaving dragons of thread”.
The dragons are Targaryens, and the spools
of thread are Viserys’s bloodline.
The “spool of green” is Viserys’ children
with Alicent, cause Alicent’s family are
called the greens.
The “spool of black” is Rhaenyra and her
kids.
The hand turning the loom might refer to the
Hand of the King Otto Hightower – cause
it was Otto’s manipulation that got Alicent
with Viserys and started the spool of green.
Looms and thread can symbolise fate and destiny.
Like the Fates in real mythology who weave
the threads of human destiny on a loom.
It seems that Helaena has prophetic dreams
of the future, giving her glimpses of the
fabric of human destiny.
But her visions aren’t very helpful when
no one listens to her.
Helaena is now betrothed to marry her brother
Aegon.
Incest is traditional for the Targaryens – Aegon
the Conqueror married his sisters, King Jaehaerys
married his sister, and Viserys and Daemon’s
parents were siblings.
The Targaryens do this to keep their blood
pure, and to keep their dragonriding genes
in the family.
Aegon and Helaena’s mother Alicent previously
seemed disgusted by Targaryen incest.
She is a religious woman, and the Faith of
the Seven considers incest an abomination
– the Faith tolerates Targaryen incest only
reluctantly.
So how does Alicent feel her about her children
marrying each other?
Maybe it was Viserys’ idea, and she just
went along with it.
Or maybe Alicent put aside her morality, and
supported this marriage because it’s useful
politically.
Alicent wants Aegon to inherit the Throne.
And marrying his sister makes Aegon seem more
like a legitimate traditional Targaryen king,
someone who will produce Targaryen dragonriding
heirs.
Aegon was probably named Aegon like Aegon
the Conqueror for the same reason, to make
him seem like a true king.
But aside from the name, Alicent’s son is
not much like Aegon the Conqueror.
All Aegon wants is to drink and hit on girls.
It’s the second son Aemond who is more dutiful,
and more focussed on their family’s strength.
So Otto Hightower is now Hand of the King
again, to replace Lyonel Strong.
Previously, Viserys fired Otto because Otto
was manipulative and biased towards his own
family.
But now he’s brought Otto back, maybe under
pressure from Alicent.
In the books, Viserys considers making Rhaenyra
Hand of the King.
But then he doesn’t because that might cause
conflict between Rhaenyra and Alicent.
So instead of dealing with this conflict,
Viserys just does the easy thing and lets
Otto have power, despite the fact that Otto
obviously doesn’t support Viserys’ chosen
heir Rhaenyra.
The old hatred between Daemon and Otto is
not forgotten – Daemon calls Otto a leech.
So everyone marinates in their unhappiness,
and glares at each other meaningfully.
Alicent hates Rhaenyra, Rhaenyra wants Daemon,
Viserys tries to reunite with Daemon, and
Daemon pretends he doesn’t need anyone.
Viserys mistakenly calls Alicent “Aemma”.
Aemma was the name of Viserys’ previous
wife.
It seems like Viserys’ sickness is affecting
his mind.
Which is scary – if the king loses his marbles,
who will hold this broken family and this
kingdom together?
It also shows that Aemma is still on Viserys’
mind.
The actor and writers say that Viserys made
Rhaenyra heir as an act of love for Aemma.
Viserys still feels guilty for Aemma’s death
and sees Rhaenyra as the last remnant of the
woman he loved and still loves.
Rhaenys and Corlys mourn their dead daughter
Laena.
Rhaenys says again that Corlys’ political
ambitions put their children in danger.
To honour Laena, Rhaenys wants Laena’s daughter
Baela to inherit Driftmark – like Vaemond,
she doesn’t support Luke getting Driftmark
because Luke doesn’t have Velaryon blood.
But Corlys has a different view on legacy
– he says “History does not remember blood.
It remembers names”.
Corlys doesn’t care that Luke and Jace aren’t
really his grandkids.
Their names are still Velaryon – while Baela’s
name is Targaryen.
Corlys won’t back down on his ambitions,
and Rhaenys is frustrated.
Rhaenyra reconnects with her uncle Daemon.
They talk about their frustrations with their
partners – Daemon didn’t quite love Laena,
and Rhaenyra says Laenor is “useless”.
Rhaenyra talks about her sexual desires.
It was Daemon who awakened Rhaenyra’s desire
– when she was a teenager.
Rhaenyra never let go of that attraction,
so she kisses Daemon, and then has sex with
her uncle on the beach.
Which is a bad idea for several reasons – like,
they’re outside a funeral, Rhaenyra is married,
and they will get sand in all of their crevices,
but Rhaenyra and Daemon find deep satisfaction
in putting aside their duties and politics
and lies and just indulging their true desires.
Meanwhile, Aemond fulfils his desire.
He wants a dragon to fulfil his birthright
as a Targaryen prince, to get power and freedom,
to stop the other kids bullying him with pigs.
In the books, Viserys suggests that Aemond
could claim a dragon egg or a hatchling on
Dragonstone.
There are also older dragons like Vermithor
and Silverwing available.
But Aemond wants nothing less than the biggest
most powerful dragon in the world – Vhagar.
With her first rider Visenya, Vhagar fought
in Aegon’s Conquest alongside Balerion the
Black Dread and Meraxes.
She has burned and battled all across Westeros.
Most recently, Vhagar was Laena Velaryon’s
dragon, but with Laena dead, Vhagar is available
again.
So Aemond finds Vhagar sleeping on the beach.
According to the Ringer-Verse podcast, a Hot
D sound designer said Vhagar is “old, lonely,
and has IBS”, and they made a “gigantic”
fart sound for Vhagar which sadly HBO did
not use.
The books say that Vhagar has become “sleepy”
in her ancient age, and she does not like
being woken up.
But Aemond is brave, and as a true Targaryen,
he has the dragonrider blood that makes it
possible to control dragons – it looks like
Vhagar can smell Aemond’s dragon blood.
Aemond commands Vhagar in Valyrian – he
says “Dohaeras”, meaning serve, and “Lykiri”
meaning “Be calm”.
He mounts Vhagar, and says “Soves” meaning
fly.
And so Aemond rides the greatest dragon through
the sky.
He almost falls off a few times – you are
meant to chain your belt to the saddle so
you don’t fall off.
But Aemond survives, proves his manhood, and
bonds with the most powerful weapon of war
in this world.
Once a rider bonds with a dragon, no one else
can control the dragon until the rider dies.
So Rhaena and Baela are angry.
Vhagar was their mother’s dragon, so they
wanted Rhaena to claim Vhagar.
There’s no rule that a dragonrider’s child
gets their parent’s dragon.
Like, before Laena, Vhagar’s rider was Baelon
Targaryen, but Baelon’s sons didn’t get
Vhagar, Laena took her.
But it’s certainly a faux par to take Vhagar
on the night of Laena’s funeral.
Baela and Rhaena wake Jace and Luke, and together
they confront Aemond.
In the book, Baela and Rhaena aren’t present,
but three-year-old Joffrey Velaryon is there,
and Aemond shoves Joff into a pile of dragon
poop.
Aemond is full of adrenaline and arrogance,
drunk with new power, so he insults Rhaena,
then Rhaena and Baela attack Aemond, he fights
back, and it turns into an all-out brawl.
Which is not surprising.
Cause these boys were trained to fight and
to see each other as enemies.
And the adults taught them that bastardy is
a shameful deadly secret.
So when Aemond calls Jace and Luke “Bastards”
and Strongs, and threatens the brothers, Luke
slashes Aemond’s face, taking his eye.
In the previous episode, Helaena said that
to get a dragon, Aemond would “have to close
an eye”.
She saw the future, probably in her dreams.
Aemond later says it’s okay he lost an eye,
because he gained the power of Vhagar.
In mythology, the sacrifice of an eye can
grant godlike power.
In the aftermath, King Viserys tries to make
peace.
Alicent sides with Aemond, Rhaenyra sides
with her own sons, and everyone’s pissed.
Daemon seems to enjoy the conflict and chaos.
“It felt like he was happy to watch them
all implode”.
“He's a leaner, Daemon.
I always liked the idea that he sort of leans”.
Jace and Luke say that Aemond called them
bastards, and Rhaenyra says this is high treason,
and “Aemond must be sharply questioned”.
‘Sharp questioning’ is a euphemism for
torture in interrogation.
So it’s pretty extreme for Rhaenyra to demand
the torture of an already mutilated child
because that child told the truth about Rhaenyra’s
infidelity, that is.. brazen.
Rhaenyra brings up these allegations to force
a confrontation, maybe hoping that King Viserys
will publicly side with her not with Alicent.
Aegon says “Everyone knows” that Jace
and Luke are bastards, just look at them.
So the deadly treasonous truth is spoken,
and King Viserys fails to resolve anything.
He just shouts at everyone in general to just
be cool and be friends please, with his empty
shirt sleeve flapping impotently.
Then he tries to leave as though the problem
is solved.
But no one is satisfied.
The king fails to make justice.
This whole scene is similar to Episode 2 of
Game of Thrones, when Arya Stark fights Joffrey,
then King Robert fails to make peace.
The Lannisters and Starks just learn to hate
each other more, and the king’s failure
to make justice plants the seeds for war.
So Alicent tries to make her own justice.
She orders Criston to cut out Luke’s eye,
to pay the debt of Aemond’s lost eye.
Criston refuses – he’s not mad enough
to mutilate a prince, but Alicent is.
She takes Viserys’ Valyrian steel knife
and attacks.
After a lifetime of suppressing her emotions,
of sacrificing her desires for the sake of
others’ expectations, acting courteous and
proper at all times, she finally explodes
with murderous rage.
Alicent says that while she’s always done
her duty, Rhaenyra constantly breaks the rules
with her bastards, and lies, flaunting her
freedom with sex and dragonflight.
Alicent is bitterly envious that Rhaenyra
gets to do what she wants without consequence,
and now even escapes justice for the mutilation
of Alicent’s son.
But Rhaenyra says that Alicent’s righteousness
is a cloak, an excuse – that Alicent acts
like she’s better than Rhaenyra, but really
she’s just motivated by petty envy and spite.
The tragedy of this fight is that Rhaenyra
and Alicent were once best friends.
Alicent’s actor said Alicent and Rhaenyra
would've been much stronger together, but
they were driven apart by this political system
– with its restrictions on women’s sexuality,
and on bastards, and its demand for one bloodline
to dominate all others.
It’s cause of the ambitions of men like
Otto, who made Alicent marry Viserys in the
first place – that politics is what drove
Rhaenyra and Alicent apart, that’s why Alicent’s
life sucks, but Alicent projects all her anger
at Rhaenyra.
Rhaenyra is cut with the knife, and their
conflict draws first blood.
The king says he’s done and walks off, leaving
his daughter bleeding at his wife’s hands,
leaving his son mutilated, leaving his family
divided.
The Valyrian steel dagger lies on the floor.
This dagger represents the prophecy of Aegon
the Conqueror, the need for House Targaryen
to be united to save the world from the white
walkers.
Viserys fails to uphold this sacred responsibility,.
Rhaenyra stands with Daemon and the Velaryons,
and Alicent with her sons and Criston.
Rhaenyra later calls Alicent’s side “the
greens”, and in the books Rhaenyra’s side
is called “the blacks”.
Peace between them now seems impossible.
Alicent feels guilty and shocked by her violent
outburst.
Rhaenyra said earlier that Alicent isn’t
capable of cold murder.
But Daemon replied that everyone is capable
of depravity.
Now, Alicent finds the depravity within herself,
and she’s horrified.
But her father Otto is glad.
He’s happy that Alicent has the determination
to win this ugly game, to get Aegon on the
Throne for their house.
He’s also fine with Aemond losing an eye
– it’s worth it to get Vhagar.
So Otto’s family is spiralling into violence,
his daughter assaulting royalty, his grandkid
losing body parts and riding a deadly scaly
nuke, and Otto couldn’t be more proud.
Rhaenyra get stitched up with thread, like
Aemond is stitched up with thread.
This might represent the green and black thread
Helaena mentioned earlier.
Laenor Velaryon is having a bad time.
The death of his sister Laena made Laenor
think about his own life.
And he’s realised that he has failed as
a husband to Rhaenyra, and as an adoptive
father to Jace Luke and Joff.
Rhaenyra mentions that she and Laenor did
try to conceive children together.
In the book, Mushroom says that Rhaenyra Laenor
and Qarl had threesomes together.
But they failed to make a child.
It is important that Rhaenyra and Laenor tried
to produce legitimate children.
Cause that means that Rhaenyra was justified
in making kids with someone else – she needs
heirs, and couldn’t get them from Laenor.
Though it would’ve been smarter to have
kids with someone who at least looked like
Laenor, rather than with Harwin, whose appearance
makes the bastardy obvious.
Laenor says he wishes he wasn’t born gay.
But Rhaenyra says Laenor’s a good person,
regardless of how society demonises his sexuality.
Rhaenyra’s sexuality is scrutinised as well,
and we see how unfair that is when males like
Aegon get to fug around with no consequences.
Laenor takes responsibility for his failures.
He says he’ll stop seeing his boyfriend
Qarl, and will instead dedicate himself to
Rhaenyra and their family.
He says he’ll sacrifice his happiness for
the sake of his duty.
In Thrones, Aemon says that love is the death
of duty, so Laenor prepares to give up his
love.
Alicent leaves Driftmark, and Corlys and Rhaenys
watch as Vhagar, their daughter’s dragon,
and the greatest weapon in this world, leaves
their control in Aemond’s hands.
Larys Strong slides into Alicent’s DMs and
offers to do a murder – or to get an eyeball
for her, or whatever she wants.
We know he’s capable of anything, after
he burned his own family with his fireflies.
Maybe Larys wants to please Alicent cause
he’s creepily obsessed with her, or maybe
he wants to make this conflict worse to use
chaos to gain power, or maybe he just loves
killin’.
But his offer is like a Faustian pact, a deal
with the devil – he tempts her with power,
but his evil may taint or trap Alicent.
Alicent tells him not to kill anyone – yet
– but that the day will come.
With Larys and Criston and Otto, Alicent is
surrounded by violent men, she’s got three
devils on her shoulder and no angel.
Rhaenyra tells Daemon that fire cost them
both what they love – cause Rhaenyra’s
lover Harwin and Daemon’s wife Laena both
died in fire.
Fire is destructive, but she says that as
Targaryens, fire is their nature, and they
were made to burn together.
Rhaenyra proposes marriage to Daemon, both
as a political alliance against Alicent’s
greens, and as a fulfilment of their true
desires.
Rhaenyra and Daemon have both had loveless
marriages of duty.
Now they want a marriage of passion and power,
of fire and blood, of uncle and niece.
But they can’t marry while Rhaenyra is married
to Laenor.
So Rhaenyra and Daemon plan to fake Laenor’s
death.
Daemon gets Laenor’s boyfriend Qarl to stage
a fake fight with Laenor.
Daemon murders some guy, and they burn the
body, so everyone thinks that Qarl killed
and burned Laenor.
Rhaenyra wants people to think that she paid
Qarl to kill Laenor.
She wants people to think she’s a killer,
so that as a ruler, she’ll be feared.
She doesn’t want to be disrespected as a
weak ruler like her father Viserys is.
But the truth is that Rhaenyra loves Laenor,
she appreciates his devotion earlier, so she
sets him free, lets him choose love over duty.
So Laenor rows into the sunset with Qarl.
Laenor shaves his head to hide his Velaryon
identity, to free himself from the restrictions
of his responsibilities.
Laenor leaves his family, and his dragon Seasmoke,
which would be hard.
Laenor loves Seasmoke – can a dragonrider
ever really separate from their dragon?
In Game of Thrones, Daenerys tries to separate
from her dragons, but that doesn’t last.
The dragonrider bond is deep – and magic.
There are hints in the books that dragons
can sense their riders’ location – so
maybe Seasmoke will try to find Laenor.
But that would reveal to everyone that Laenor’s
still alive.
Also, as long as Laenor is alive it may be
impossible for anyone new to bond with Seasmoke,
and that could give away that Laenor’s alive.
So as a Valyrian dragonrider, can Laenor really
escape his destiny?
When Daemon went east, he couldn’t stay
away.
Laenor’s escape is a change from the books.
In the books it seems that Laenor really is
killed by Qarl – but Fire & Blood is all
about unreliable narrators, and historians
not knowing the full truth.
So Hot D can give us these twists to surprise
even people who’ve read the books.
With Laenor gone, Rhaenyra and Daemon get
married in an ancient Valyrian ritual.
Maybe Daemon learned about this from those
Valyrian books in Pentos.
All Valyrian sorcery is rooted in blood or
fire.
So they’re surrounded by candles, and wear
fiery clothes, and they draw blood with dragonglass
– the special volcanic rock found on Dragonstone
that can kill white walkers.
They draw Valyrian glyphs on each other that
mean fire and blood.
So this wedding is not like Rhaenyra and Daemon’s
previous marriages.
This one is passionate and grand, with the
weight and possibly the magic of ancient ceremony.
Rhaenyra says this marriage strengthens Rhaenyra’s
claim to the Throne.
Because it combines Rhaenyra’s claim as
Viserys’ daughter with Dameon’s claim
as Viserys’ brother.
But this also might turn people against Rhaenyra.
Some people don’t want Daemon anywhere near
the Throne, because he’s so violent and
unpredictable.
And it may be seen as an insult that Rhaenyra
and Daemon remarried so soon after Laena and
Laenor’s apparent deaths.
King Viserys will be pissed, because this
royal marriage happened without his permission.
And the apparent death of Laenor could weaken
Rhaenyra’s alliance with the Velaryons.
Will the Corlys and Rhaenys think that Rhaenyra
killed their son, or will Rhaenyra tell them
the truth?
Like fire, this marriage is powerful but dangerous.
Rhaenyra’s actor says Rhaenyra and Daemon
are “a terrible match” because they’re
so similar, they are have a “dangerous chemistry”.
Rhaenyra has wanted this marriage for a long
time.
But will Daemon be a good husband?
He doesn’t have a great track record.
So as divisions deepen between Alicent’s
greens and Rhaenyra’s blacks, both sides
turn to their darkest most dangerous allies.
The whole royal family spirals towards blood
and fire.
If you wanna know the full story of the Targaryens,
you’ve gotta check out the Game of Thrones
books – there’s the main series, the worldbook,
Dunk & Egg, and Fire & Blood, which tells
the story of Hot D is in Fire & Blood.
You can get any one of these on audiobook
for free right now at audible.com/asx.
Sign up for a Premium Plus trial membership,
and you get an audiobook to keep, even if
you cancel the trial.
You can get any Game of Thrones book, or Lord
of the Rings, or Dune.
Membership also includes unlimited access
to thousands of audiobooks and shows in the
Audible Plus Catalog.
Sign up at audible.com/asx, or text asx to
500-500.
Thanks for watching, please like and subscribe
and check out the podcast feeds linked below.
Thank you to the Patrons, including Samia
Javaid, Greg Nemes, callmecatalyst, ToyButton,
Matthew Chiaravalloti, Classless, and Yanek.
Cheers.